[Musique]
oh, c'est un peu bouleversant à la fin, n'est-ce pas,
elle était très intelligente, la
personne la plus intelligente que je connaissais, elle était si
tout à fait
authentique Amy, fais-nous juste un sourire et
ensuite nous pourrons éteindre la caméra, tu
promets
[Musique]
elle  J'ai eu une telle relation émotionnelle avec
la musique que tu deviens un artiste dans le
public, plus les gens me voient,
plus ils se rendront compte que tout ce pour quoi je suis bon,
c'est faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] de la
musique et le Grammy revient à Amy  Wi
House est l'un des tests les plus vrais que j'ai jamais
entendus. Le monde voulait un morceau d'elle.
[Musique]
Amy était une fille qui voulait juste être
aimée. Je me sentais amoureux de quelqu'un pour qui je
serais mort
et c'est comme si une vraie drogue n'était pas.  Ce n'est pas
[Musique]
c'est quelqu'un qui essaie de
[Applaudissements]
disparaître
[Musique]
le truc c'est que je ne pense pas que je vais
être du tout [
Musique] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
célèbre je  je ne suis pas une fille qui essaie d'être une
star
[Musique]
je fais juste
des trucs